all right Ryan today is actually our
favorite holiday giving Tuesday I love I
love how they have I think after
everyone is like you know gets soiled
with guilt from going out and over
spending over the weekend with Black
Friday and what Cyber Monday it's like
you can you can rinse yourself clean
yeah there's also a small building
Tuesday a Small Business Saturday that
just happened and it's cool too III dig
that but it really combines two of your
favorite things Giving and Tuesdays why
do I love Tuesdays why you love Tuesdays
you're the one that loves Tuesdays Oh
we'll never know yeah but it's it's
giving Tuesday and we had a special
guest on this episode of the podcast
named Scott Harrison he started a great
nonprofit called
charity water and you for those of you
who have been with us for a while you
know that we've worked with them to
build a bunch of clean water wells in
different countries throughout the world
and thank you for the folks who have
helped us out in the past we've been
working with them for over five years
now
and we're doing something new with them
that they just launched a new project
and you'll hear Scott talk about it but
you're interested in contributing even
five bucks if you were saying I'm
looking for a way to contribute beyond
myself today is giving Tuesday
let me help some folks who are truly in
need because there are so many people
who don't even have access to clean
water in the world
you can head on over to charity
water.org slash the minimalists you can
see this great video that Scott put
together and we really encourage you to
give whatever you can give even if it's
a few bucks I know it may not seem like
it's a whole lot but it certainly helps
so especially with the size of our
audience if all of you were to
contribute something we would do
something really special in this world I
won't belabor it too much because Scott
does a much more eloquent job of
describing what they do and what their
mission is so let's go ahead and dive
into this episode oh and we answer a
bunch of questions as well this was a
live event our first ever event in
Brooklyn New York and we had three stops
in New York and he joined us for that he
helped us answers for questions as well
and man is he he's a brilliant guy
alright y'all enjoy the show we demand
it
[Laughter]
[Music]
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your greed oh I bet that you'd
be fine without me live from the Bell
House Theatre
my name is Joshua fields Milburn and I
am Ryan Nicodemus and together we are
the minimalists live in Brooklyn whoo oh
man that's that Brooklyn welcome I was
looking for ya
it's so great to be back in New York
we're doing three nights in New York
this time around but this is our very
first time in Brooklyn so thank you for
being here with us tonight so we have a
special guest with us tonight you know
we usually record a podcast we're gonna
answer some of your questions I've been
told there's a microphone back there
somewhere what will happen is one person
will start the line they have to break
the seal and then people will cascade
from the rafters and everywhere else to
get to the mic and so whoever wants to
ask the first question we will get to
that in a moment
but first I'd like to introduce a
special guest who will help us answer
some questions hopefully tonight during
our talk tonight you're you heard me and
Ryan we talked a little bit about
contribution and there's there's a
saying that I believe to be true and
it's giving his living and and I
realized that one of the things that was
missing from sort of my past life my
especially like these solipsistic 20s is
I was living mostly for me and for my
own desires and I think that's important
I think personal development and growth
and and fulfilling your needs and even
your once adding having things that add
value to your life and experiences that
value your life all those things are
important but it's not important if you
can't also give you can't contribute
beyond yourself and so one of the
reasons Ryan and I do what we do is we
hope
share a recipe for those of you who were
dragged here tonight that this this
isn't a cult don't worry no one's trying
to convert you to minimalism I don't
know that's even possible but but what
we're trying to do is simply share a
recipe and hopes it adds value to your
lives it's a small way that we can
contribute but there are other ways that
we try to contribute as well within the
last few years we've done been able to
do some pretty cool things we've built
some elementary schools we've funded
high schools clean water wells and we
are helping the folks in in Houston
right now where we're doing a charity
event down there we're also donating
money and encouraging other people to
donate to global giving but yeah thank
you we we like to contribute and also
encourage other people to contribute
contribute but our our our bit of
contribution pales in comparison to our
guest he's someone who has been obsessed
with water for the last decade and I'm
gonna let him tell his story because
he's gonna do it so much better than me
but I'm grateful to share the stage with
some we don't do interviews on our
podcasts and we don't even have podcast
guests ever but occasionally we'll bring
a friend on and and and have a little
discussion with them so please welcome
charity waters Scott Harrison
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so yeah you got the memo come in and
yeah we're all for those of you
listening at home we're all dressed in
black right now except for my purple
socks and Ryan's orange shoelaces look
at you you definitely got the memo this
is great
so you're obsessed with water and I
drank water today what a coincidence but
but it's weird because I take it for
granted right I I turned on a faucet in
my hotel room by the way this is like
our first legit tour we've been on eight
tours in seven years and when it started
with our first tour was in 2011 and we
would go to a bookstore and a really
great crowd would be like six people
I remember our fourth tour stop we
showed up in Knoxville Tennessee and no
one was there
it was very humbling except right as we
were leaving two people showed up we've
never been shut out we had quite a few
nights where there were two people yeah
and we were on the lucky nights we would
be able to sleep on a readers floor or
maybe their couch one of us would be on
the couch one of us would be on the
floor on an unlucky night we'd sleep at
a rest stop in our tour bus which is
Ryan's Toyota Corolla and and now this
is like legit tour because you all paid
to get in and so we have a hotel room
and I can go right to the faucet and I
turn on the water and it just comes out
and I'm able to drink it but that's not
the case all over the world and so can
you talk to me a little bit about other
people's lack of this thing that we take
for granted yeah sure hey everybody it's
great to be here it's great to share a
little bit of our story yeah so for ten
years now we've been working on trying
to bring clean drinking water to
everyone on earth and a tenth of the
world doesn't have the same opportunity
that you had today
and really everyday so about 660 million
people because of where they're born are
drinking dirty water every single day
that could kill them and often does kill
them and their their children so it's a
it's a big problem water is this
interesting thing that touches so many
aspects of life that you don't think
about until you don't have and it's
funny people tweeted charity water all
the time when their water gets shut off
it's like the number one oh my my you
know my doorman building had no water
today we're not asking you to fix it
right they don't want you to fix the
water no no okay it's one of those
things that on you just never think
about right until that one day that's
it's turned off in your building for
like an hour and a half and oh my gosh
what are you gonna do right so so we
we've worked in I mean I'll just give
you a a sense of how bad it is if you
don't have water so we work in 24
countries around the world I've now been
to 66 countries you know doing this work
and another and one of the places we
work as an Ethiopia so the communities
where we we work the people that we
serve the it's the job of the girls and
the women to get the water so first of
all the men never get water I don't care
if we're in India Bangladesh Central and
South America sub-saharan Africa the men
at best are farming at worst they're
drinking and it's the job of the wives
you know the women and the girls to go
and get the water after they're done
getting the water they have to get the
firewood they have to go cook it's a
there's a lot of extra activities there
but the women are spending often up to 8
hours every day walking back and forth
for the water and they're walking to
sources like ponds swamps rivers you
know contaminated sources we wouldn't
let our animals drink from just to give
you you know a sense of one of these
villages I was living in a village in
Ethiopia a couple years ago where a 13
year old girl had been walking for water
every single day she - she carried a
heavy clay pot on her back so imagine 60
pounds of water about 40 pounds of water
20 pounds for the clay pot and one day
after her 8 hour round trip walks it's
about
three out and then you have to fill up
your water and then it's heavy so it's a
little slower back before she gets home
she slips and falls
so she breaks her clay pot she spills
all the water and she doesn't go back
and get more water she ties a noose
around her neck she climbs a tree and
she hangs herself so the elders of the
village are walking by and they find
this 13o girl's body swinging from a
tree and I live in this village the the
crazy thing was that nothing changed
after her death the women just continued
going to the same source continued
walking eight hours walking past this
tree that had claimed the life of this
young girl and it's it's I mean it's
really that extreme you know the the
walk in the health you know 52 percent
of all disease throughout the developing
world is caused by bad water in a lack
of toilets so half of the people that
are sick don't need to be sick if they
just had this basic need man and again
you know we're we were born into the
privilege of having water and having
being able to take long showers so how
did you stumble into this what what made
you passionate about of all the things
you can do in terms of contribution I
mean this the this seems it is so
necessary but but what what was the path
for you to get there well it's funny I'm
sitting in the back with my wife
listening to to your stories mine is so
similar you know I started chasing the
American dream of more I was born into a
very conservative Christian family my
mom became an invalid when I was four
there was a carbon dioxide gas leak in
her house I had this weird childhood
with sickness and illness and I was an
only child and a caregiver role and then
at 18 I just went freaking nuts moved to
New York City and became a club promoter
you know I couldn't believe that you
could actually get paid to drink alcohol
for free in the city I mean if you got a
Revell you might as a rebellion style so
I spent the next 10 years filling up
nightclubs with thousands of the right
people charging them you know $500 to
buy a bottle of champagne that cost 50
and 20 dollars a cocktail in the one-way
glass and the velvet ropes and trying to
accumulate all the things that you see
on TV that we saw you know among our
clients the Rolex watch that I got the
BMW that I drove the grand piano in my
New York apartment the girlfriend who
was on the cover of magazines the the
Labrador Retriever I mean you go step by
step and it's almost like it was
connecting it was it was
paint-by-numbers for consumerism right
like for sure ed the magazine from cover
to cover and you'll I'll take that one
and that one and that and that and yeah
of course you were happy then right it
was miserable I mean again you know I
resonated with so much of what you're
saying earlier it looked great on the
outside so people looking from the
outside like wow this dude parties for a
living like we worked three nights a
week we flew around the world a fashion
week you know we jumped in the back of
you know cars with drivers and we were
taken around to fancy dinners and but
you know somewhere around noon you know
for a plate of cocaine I mean it was
pretty dark I mean the dinner at 10:00
the club at 12:00 after hours at 5:00
and I just remember remember this once
on Houston Street it was around noon and
I was trying to come down from the whole
night out and I looked out the window
and people are on their lunch break like
people had been you know they've gone to
work that day they were going to lunch
and I was gonna try to go to bed wake up
at 6:00 7:00 p.m. and then do it all
over again so you know I came to my
senses I was I was 28 I was in a
vacation in South America and I just had
this this moment of reflection realizing
that I was spiritually bankrupt I was
morally bankrupt I'd come I'd really
betrayed the spiritual and moral
heritage of my youth and if I continue
down this path as a selfish hedonist
like sycophant that I would leave no
meaningful legacy you know my tombstone
would read here lies Scott Harrison who
got 10 million people wasted you know I
mean I realize if I made it to 40 I
would look a hundred and there was a
good chance I wouldn't make it to 40 I
mean people were dying like crazy you
know we would take the wrong thing by an
accident and it was a really destructive
lifestyle so you know I start to start
to re-explore a very lost faith and I
think in a different way as an adult you
know it wasn't force-fed to me and I
become really interested in the idea of
service and service to others and now
ask this question what would the exact
opposite of my life look like what would
it look like instead of you know getting
drunk every night and trying to
accumulate more things you know more
more money more status more Fame you
know better parties what would it look
like to try and use my time and talent
and energy in the service of others so
I'm a pretty radical guy I sold
everything my kind of cluttered
declutter story I put up two thousand
DVDs on eBay and they were worth
something by the way 14 years ago in a
single lot I just purged my life and I
began to apply to the famous
humanitarian organizations in the world
you know the great nightclub promoter is
now ready for humanitarian service so
they all turned me down literally I'm
denied by every single organization
because of course they're serious people
doing serious work in Africa and like
I'm some drunk in New York City and yeah
you know finally one organization writes
me back and says if I'm willing to pay
them $500 a month
I can volunteer
that's called a scam where I come from
and I have to go live in Liberia
post-war Liberia this is a country I'd
never even heard of before they just
come out of a 14-year Civil War led by
Charles Taylor and child soldiers and
some like here my credit card details
you know when does this start and they
said three weeks so so my whole life
changed in the instant as I joined this
humanitarian mission of medical doctors
and surgeons who would give up their
vacation time effectively and fly to
Liberia and operate on people who had no
access to medical care people who
couldn't afford procedures and I wound
up dedicating a year that turned into
two and among all the things that I saw
living in a leprosy colony seeing you
know facial tumors and flesh-eating
disease and people who've been burned by
rebels during the war crazy crazy things
I I saw people drinking from swamps and
I just had never seen a child drink you
know green viscous water before I was
selling bottles of water of VAS water
specifically in nightclubs for ten
dollars to people who would come in
they'd order 20 and not even open them
it was just a show of status so I just
couldn't believe that you know there was
this extremity there's this huge wide
gap between 1/10 of the world just born
into these situations not born into the
middle-class privilege that I was and
that I could use some of the things I
had learned promoting nightclubs and you
know telling the wrong story perhaps to
to maybe tell a redemptive story that
would actually help people yeah I think
we don't think about it I mean even
though I grew up really poor like dirt
poor food stamps government assistance I
never thought about water even you know
it we thought about a line and we
struggle a lot but we certainly didn't
struggle with water and so I think most
of us we don't even we don't even think
about it it's such a luxury to to not
even think about it
so we try to find different projects to
Ryan and I contribute to and we we
started contributing to charity water on
a monthly basis personally
but we want to hopefully inspire our
audience and people in the audience who
can afford to contribute a small amount
to do that as well if you feel compelled
if you're like I really like to help
some people get access to to clean water
Scott and his whole team have have made
a short film it's actually a relatively
long film and if you go to charity water
19 minutes which is thank you forever
today on the Internet
right it's like can you get it on vine
but it's it's a really compelling film
and so if you go to charity water.org
slash the minimalists you can contribute
whatever you want and I'll tell you one
thing that I've done recently just
within the last year is I've started to
automate my giving to make it in charity
water isn't the only place I contribute
to there are plenty of other great
places I go to give well.org and against
malaria foundation but charity water is
one of the places where I've automated
and I give a small amount every single
month because I know that that what
they're doing with their money and can
you talk just a little bit before we
dive into some questions and hopefully
you'll stick around for some questions
he talked about the the charity water
model because the money that is donated
isn't just for isn't for administrative
cost so I'll take you back ten years so
this would be my life's mission would be
to try to create a day on earth when
everyone in clean water to drink and you
know we were 660 million people away
from that day as I started talking my
friends you know I was thirty I was
naive I hadn't come out of the
charitable sector or I really wasn't
influenced by the trappings of the big
kind of bureaucratic institutions so I
start talking to my friends and I
realized there's this huge distrust none
of my friends trust charities at the end
of the day they're asking questions like
where does the money go how much of my
money is actually gonna reach people yes
it gonna get there at all and I started
to see the data behind this you know you
guys know America's one of the most
generous countries in the world 42% of
Americans distrust charities so almost
half the eligible givers in the country
don't
trust the system you know and there you
know we we all have one scandal we can
probably remember I remember for a
period of time Anderson Cooper used to
like chase down the bad charity CEOs to
their McMansion and they would slam the
door and he's sitting there on the you
know and all of America throws up their
hands and say that's why I don't give I
don't trust those crooks and why you did
a recent study that polled Americans and
found that 72% of Americans said they
they believe charities either waste
money or badly waste money so that was
really a problem I was trying to solve
to help bring clean water to millions or
tens of millions or hundreds of millions
I thought we just needed a new model to
win back that trust that had been
betrayed to take a disenchanted public
people who really wanted to be generous
they wanted to give but didn't trust the
system so we had a couple ideas in the
beginning I thought what if we could
give away a hundred percent of every
donation we ever received in perpetuity
and only use it to directly fund water
projects and and be so extreme about
protecting the integrity 100% we'd even
pay back credit card fees so if you gave
a hundred bucks on your Amex and we
actually received ninety-seven somehow
we would figure out how to make up the
$3.00 difference and send all hundred
dollars of the field so people said at
the beginning that's the stupidest thing
they ever heard like you know we used to
have a staff like how will you rent an
office how would you even pay for a
flight to go to develop your water
programs and I just believed that we
would be able to find a very small group
of individuals if we did it right who
would be builders who didn't want their
name on a well they didn't want their
name on a water project they would
actually want to pay for this salaries
the unsexy stuff the copiers the toner
the insurance the phone bill and that
would be we would basically make our
lives double was hard because we'd have
to start two organizations from scratch
we would have to fund them effectively
separately they were there literally two
bank accounts at charity water that are
audited separately and then we'd have to
run them in perfect balance but I just
believe that you know people wouldn't be
able to use that excuse how much of my
money goes 100 percent what's next so
then we we said well now the money's not
fungible why don't we use technology to
track ads why don't we show people the
photos in the
yes coordinates of every water project
we build around the world let's put
everything up on Google Maps Google
Earth you know let's build the first
kind of hyper transparent organization
where we could track a $4 donation that
a ten-year-old you know got at a
lemonade stand and say your 4 dollars
went up in this 11,000 $221 water
projects in Malawi and here the people
you shared it with so we just you know
we built the movement on social media we
never direct mailed you know I mean the
thought of a charity buying your
physical mailing addresses and then
sending you paper just seems stupid to
us yeah so you know I spoke at Twitter
when there were 28 employees and we
became the first charity to get a
million Twitter followers in the first
charity to use Instagram and really just
tried to build a community and celebrate
our supporters in the diversity of the
community what they were doing and then
we wanted to build a beautiful brand and
my wife is here tonight she was the
second employee at the organization and
we had come across this quote in the New
York Times by Nick Kristof that said
toothpaste is peddled with far more
sophistication than all the world's
life-saving causes you know if you think
about this junk food companies can spend
half a billion dollars marketing to us
things that kill us and kill our
children but they're the most important
causes that are saving people's lives
that are feeding people that are giving
them clean water that are providing
shelter often have anemic brands they
you know they still send non
mobile-optimized
emails today drives me crazy like you
know expecting us to you know scroll
with her ok hire a 22 year old that does
responsive design you know like this is
this is what you see where was the where
was the night key of charities where was
the Apple where was the Virgin the Tesla
you know where were the charities that
were inspiring people that were creating
imaginative experiences and you know so
many charities just use guilt and shame
and they make people feel horrible about
how much they have and and then say you
know reach into your wallet and nobody
wants to wear the t-shirt of that
charity it may work you may give money
so we just tried to basically you know
look at all the things that people were
doing and say what would the exact
opposite look like what would it look
like to build a brand not imagine
and hope and opportunity and invite
people in to be a part of something
amazing invite people to be a part of a
world where everyone has clean water to
to create that legacy for their kids and
their grandkids and then the most
important thing was just not sending
people that look like me to Africa to
actually go do the work and and weed
seed so many people send Westerners to
Africa India Southeast Asian just not
really understand the local context not
get things right so our job would be to
get people to care about this issue get
him to give generously be great stewards
of their money but then the work would
all be done by the locals it would be
sustainable and led by the locals they
would be the heroes they would be the
ones flying the flag getting the credit
you know today we employ over 500 people
in Ethiopia there is not a single expat
on the entire staff so 500 Ethiopians
are out there every single day using the
money from from you guys from us from
this community but they are turning it
into clean water for their own people so
that was 10 years ago and and you know
similar to you guys you know that first
month like a couple people came out and
then a few more in a few more and it
grew now to over a million people have
given a quarter of a billion dollars to
help 7.1 million people get clean water
so and what's what's different now I
mean so I can tell you this so you go
back I'm 36 now remember you were your
charity was actually the friend ever
talk to you about this but your charity
was the first chair that really
compelled me to not just contribute but
inspire other people to contribute so I
donated my birthday I've donated several
birthday since then as the minimalist
we've been able to raised tens of
thousands of dollars to build several
wells and and Malawi and and we want to
go you have to come at some point and
see them for yourselves be amazing love
to and and and so where I'm going now is
I think that once I felt compelled to
inspire other people I feel like your
your mission has shifted recently as
well is that true yeah I mean the
birthday is you know you talked about
this was the thing for years and years
and and this this is I think we're so
values aligned here we looked at the
birthday and said it's all about stuff
like we get so much crap for our
birthdays that we
want or need belts ties gift cards just
it's this commercial materialism cycle
and people don't even have clean water
so what if we could redeem the birthday
what if we could turn it into a generous
giving moment that is about others and
not about ourselves and we involve our
friends and family in something amazing
and in providing clean water so I
thought kind of the sticky marketing
idea would be to get people to ask for
their age in dollars all right so if
you're a 6 years old
you know kids with $6 it's lunch money
if you're 71 years old you know people
who can donate 71 dollars so this this
movement took out took off I mean people
now through fundraising campaigns have
raised over 50 million dollars helping
almost 2 million people get clean water
and that idea like you said it spread
the the average person that donates
their birthday gets 15 people to give to
their campaign so you have these mini
word-of-mouth movements right we're not
spending the marketing dollars doing
that and just kind of organically began
to spread so that was great and that
kind of you know helped us you know
serve 7 million people in the first
decade as we turn 10 we realized you
know the problem with the birthday is
you only do one most people only do 1
they'd actually take the idea and start
doing it for other charities so we'd see
people do their second birthday for
hunger the third birthday for just this
issue but but we kind of had to start
over every single year and and at our
tenth anniversary said look let's let's
see if we can start building a new
community people who will stick by us
month in month out giving what they can
is littles five bucks some people are
giving $30 which it costs to give one
person clean water some people give $300
and give 10 people clean water and you
know the average person now has 11
subscriptions that we benefit from the
Netflix is in Hulu's and drop boxes and
HBO's and showtimes and your magazines
your your news write 11 subscriptions
every month that we are getting the
benefit and we said what if we could
create a subscription where you get zero
benefit a hundred percent is passed on
to the poorest people in the world who
are in need of clean water and then will
try to innovate and find ways to build
community to share stories of what five
or ten dollars or thirty dollars does
every single month so that's called the
Spring
and it's it's brand-new you know it's
it's a it's a new community we've about
ten thousand people now giving from 80
different countries and that's that's
really I think the key to our success
over the next 10 years and what makes
you know the next 10 years different
than the first is building this
community it's funny what do you sent
that video I remember watching it and
you talk and spoiler alert so just the
heads up on the video but no you talk
about it men at 19 by the way probably
right but you talked about how your goal
is to provide clean water to the entire
world and if it was anyone else I'd say
they were freaking nuts man
but like I really believe that you can
do it man cuz because the organization
that you've been able to put together to
the support and yeah I don't mind
donating my birthday to and I was just
blown away
like how many people love the idea yeah
it's a really powerful idea and so we're
gonna wait until the Tuesday after Black
Friday it's called giving Tuesday to put
this actual podcast out because that's
it that's when you're in the middle of
it so back in my my corporate days I've
managed a hundred and fifty retail
stores which is really ironic I'm sorry
but we planned all year like literally
we started having weekly holiday
shopping meetings holiday shopping
season meetings in February so we were
planning for Black Friday and then that
has extended into that entire weekend
being the busiest shopping weekend and
of course the following Monday is Cyber
Monday but then after that we're like we
we feel this like the stench of
consumerism we're sitting at our desks
like how do i absolve myself and so
there's this day called givingtuesday
and so hopefully when this comes out
folks will go to charity water org slash
the minimalist you all can go there
tonight if you wanted to and and
contribute whatever you contribute we
really appreciate it and let's answer
some questions and now you want to stick
around Scott oh yeah thanks
[Applause]
first up yeah howdy what's your name hi
I'm crystal crystal are you from I'm
from Florida I just moved to New York
about three weeks ago
welcome so thank God I found minimalism
before have you been to the East River I
live near it now so I was forced to
learn you I didn't know what it was when
I moved here a few weeks ago so I can
bond with you I do have a question but I
would like to take the opportunity thank
you both because you have added value to
my life I could take an hour which I had
the time to tell you the domino effect
it added to the value with my
relationship with my husband and my
daughter
it really does Domino so anyway sorry by
the way my husband was on board when he
saw that minimalism included a hairdryer
because that is important to him that's
one of the key points to be in a
minimalist you have to have great hair
less stuff more hair
that's my pity answer next question
though oh why she didn't ask thank you
so much for that I just got to tell you
like every time I hear that like it
feels the same every single time meaning
you know if we wrote three books and
came out with a documentary and it was
just you who got something out of it
like that that means the world to me so
yeah thank you very much it's our
pleasure to do that so because of you
guys we did start following other people
I follow Rebecca and minimal wellness
you guys have not done that she is
beyond the moat the best thing you could
follow for nutrition and wellness it's
amazing it's best so my daughter have a
7 year old and she has an affinity for
kids with curly hair she doesn't have
that so she's loved seeing pictures of
is it Twitter handle shouldn't I so my
four-year-old has a Twitter account and
it's really just our way of we don't
have a scrapbook for her so it's like my
online scrapbook it's just all the crazy
[ __ ] that Ella says as a four-year-old
it's a tell sandwich for those of you on
Twitter yeah it was gonna be hurricane
Ella but that seems inappropriate this
week
oh right sorry too soon too soon job
well anyway we started we've actually
found the minimalism game by following
Rebecca and Ella when she started
joining her and so we started doing that
posting the pictures we're in the
process of moving and we're stopping and
go okay well this will be day five and
so we took those pictures and I was like
you know what in the spirit of
minimalism we're going to just like get
all this stuff out of here that's enough
with the pictures and the posting so we
were I was like let's just get all the
stuff together and then I realized what
she was on board and loved doing it and
then I saw all of her dolls everything
was all in this trash bag and I was like
well you know in a second and I thought
she so got it but she was like well here
now this is part of this is what you
like you want me to do this and then you
know my birthday and Christmas are
coming and we can replace these things
so honestly our birthdays ten days
before Christmas and you know she gets
it as much as I think she can but I
don't want to ruin those things but I
also want to direct her on the right
path you know and encourage you know the
the reasons and why and I just wanted
help with how to do that especially
around Christmas time and you know
taking away don't want to take away the
joy of like the getting or the you know
the grandmothers from giving and so so
so your question revolves around not
ruining a child's childhood by
deprivations fix that for me yeah man I
can tell you this that that Ella has
such a great life and she knows she does
and I think part of it has to do with
the habits that we're instilling I can
tell her something till I'm blue in the
face but really it comes from my own
behaviors I noticed that when she is
doing something I dislike like eating
food on her plate with her hands instead
of using a fork it's because she just
saw me like pull a piece of broccoli off
of her mom's plate with my own hand and
if I want her to be her best self I
better be my best self and and part of
that has to be with in terms of living
with less it's less stuff but it's more
of everything else it's more time
it's more experiences it's more
contentment it's it's more giving and
showing her you know whenever she's
ready to get rid of a toy now you know
she says to me I want to I want to
donate this so some other kid can play
with it so she understands what it means
to let go of the thing this doesn't end
up in this nebulous void she realizes
that someone else is gonna play with it
by the way some of her toys are used so
she realized that some other kid gave it
up and instilling that habit and in our
kids they don't they don't feel deprived
by the way like the things she'd really
loves or the silliest thing I could buy
her the nicest shiniest toy but she'll
play with a broken balloon and pretend
it's something amazing so we don't get
to determine what they find value in
yeah I so Chris I'm kidding
so Scott um the one the one thing I the
one thing I know about about kids is
that they love to contribute they love
to help and and given an opportunity to
just like with your daughter she's like
okay here's all my stuff because kids
love to help I know you've got some
really awesome stories about some kids
who have contributed to charity water do
you want maybe want to share one or two
like the best success story yeah I mean
I can share a couple I mean we've had
the the lemonade stands I would just say
exposing exposing her young to different
issues we're just we're so surprised at
the capacity kids have a young age to
understand their depth of compassion and
empathy and you know for us we'll look
at some injustice in the world and you
know we're so preconditioned to be used
to it and you know kids are like not on
my watch what can I do about this I mean
you know there was there was a little
girl named Riley Goodfellow in Orange
County and she started eating she went
on a rice and beans fast for a month she
said I'm only eating rice and beans and
I'm gonna try and raise money and she
raised $15,000 and her mom's tennis in
this picture and
it was just it was a picture of her
holding a piece of paper a bunch of
pieces of paper taped together with a
bunch of little lines and you know we
wrote her mom back and said yeah what's
up with the picture and she said well my
my daughter went on your website and saw
that 4500 kids die every day of bad
water and she asked me for paper and pen
and she started to write 4,500 lines
because she said she wanted to feel it
and took her two days to finish there
was there was another story an
eight-year-old girl in Seattle named
Rachel Beckwith who had given up her
birthday and she set a goal of raising
three hundred bucks to help ten people
get clean water and right before is that
she was an extraordinary girl already
the year before she cut her hair off and
donated it to Locks of Love like she
didn't understand you know why kids
would suffer with cancer and you know
why their hair would fall out so if her
hair could help someone else then that
was better than her having it so she
then comes across charity water see some
of the videos on our website and says I
can't believe the kids don't have clean
water so she donates her birthday she
gives up all the gifts she refuses to
have a birthday party she raises two
hundred and twenty dollars so she falls
a little shy of her goal and she tells
her mom that she's gonna try harder the
next year right after her birthday she's
killed in a car crash
there was a 20-car pileup a
tractor-trailer had lost control her mom
was driving her sister was in the front
and she was in the back seat and she was
the only fatality and her mom
contacts our office and says my
daughter's last wish was for kids she'd
never met to get clean water now we'd
like to reopen her campaign and
encourage everyone to donate nine
dollars in her honor
so this starts the story of Rachel
starts spreading as you'd imagine
through her church community through the
Seattle community starts spreading
around the country the New York Times
gets a hold of it The Morning Show
starts spreading to Europe starts
spreading to Africa and people in Africa
start donating nine dollars
for a girl in Seattle who cared about
them getting clean water more than the
stuff that we would expect her she went
up raising 1.3 million dollars over
60,000 complete strangers they lay $9
down in her honor
inspired by the depth of compassion you
know the vision of an eight-year-old
girl to consider others more important
than her stuff and the things this
happened five years ago and we got to
actually take the family on the one-year
anniversary of her death to Ethiopia to
visit village after village after
village after village that had clean
water they got to see thousands and
thousands of people and meet thousands
of people who had clean water because of
Rachel and the cool thing is now five
years later we just kind of looked at
that data set and so many of the 60,000
strangers that gave to her campaign were
inspired by her they started giving up
their birthdays they raised another two
million dollars so rachel has now
directly impacted over a hundred
thousand lives from an idea of helping
ten so I think the kids are the future
they they understand it you know in
these these stories they inspire people
to end on a happier note there was a
girl in Vancouver that just did 12
lemonade stands for charity water and
one of them in the complete rain she
would not come in even though it was
pouring rain and in her last lemonade
stand she convinces a local band to
perform on the sidewalk next to her
lemonade stand
to attract more buyers and she's now
she's now at 5,600 dollars of lemonade
so you know kids are the future I would
say expose your kids don't you know they
can they can handle this stuff younger
than we think
and they'll challenge us you know
whether it's with the concepts and the
values that you guys are talking about
if it's humanitarian issues you know we
can learn from children thank you thank
you
[Music]
we're gonna do one more question before
we move on to the lightning round so so
sit tight if you're back there we'll do
we'll do at least three lightning round
questions as well howdy what's your name
where you from what's your question
hopefully in that order yeah my name is
Mark and I'm from here in New York and
I'm here with my my wife and we who
didn't drag me here actually okay very
happily we're both getting so much I'm
glad you weren't drugged neither neither
drags nor drugged and both getting so
much out of out of your message in your
podcast and also our our nine-year-old
boy who can't come here tonight because
this is 21 and over so so we're coming
tomorrow to Philly Wow
and also I wanted to say one another
reason we're here tonight is they
decided we decided this is the perfect
way to celebrate the new year this being
the Jewish New Year so happy New Year to
all and so I had a question I'm not
saying what what I do but what my
passion is which is also what I do I I'm
a musician
and I've I'm a violinist I've been on
tour and looking at where you've come
from and where you are now you know
being in a place with with 12 people
listening and now are hundreds and in
some places I think probably thousands
then do you find that as much as you're
passionate about what you do that it is
more stressful and if so what do you do
about that or do you just say well I'm
passionate about it and so I can handle
the stress yeah no I I have a little
like mentoring side hustle that I do and
I have some some mentees and a lot of
them the first meeting we have I don't
wanna sail out some they'll say really
like what you do man I love how you know
you get your own thing going on you work
for yourself I want to do that I want to
live your life and I'm like no you
probably don't want to live my life like
I had to leave my partner Mariah for I
mean for all intents and purposes
ten months in 2014 so Josh and I could
get on the road and go on that 100 city
tour our flight back from Perth
Australia to Missoula Montana which
surprisingly you can't get that many to
write direct flights to Missoula Montana
it was something like 42 hours it was oh
and I had food poisoning on the plane it
was it was um it was it was an
interesting situation very very grueling
and um the one thing like anytime I get
um a little irritated on a plane I have
to like room I don't know if you guys
heard the Louie CK bit of Lake my ass is
flying to 500 miles an hour this is
pretty awesome there's really no reason
to be upset right now and then when I
had food poisoning I'm like and I get to
go home and see a doctor like no problem
I'll get this taken care of what I'm
getting at is is that Josh and I we are
living the dream I love it but the catch
is that living the dream it takes a lot
of hard work there's no doubt about it
now I think that there is a you know
there is this idiom that that were
raised with especially in Western
culture of you know if if you find what
you love to do you'll never work again a
day in your life [ __ ]
I mean at when it all comes down to it
that might be true for some fewer than
some but that is that is probably not
the right expectation for people to have
so to answer your question yes it's hard
work man it is a lot of hard work and
you know we just Josh and I moved
recently Mariah would be here with me
but you know she was at home like
cleaning our place and getting
everything in order and thank God that I
have a supportive partner to that
totally supports me in doing this work
so for me it's you know when it comes
down to the hard work that I put in what
I look at is like what am I getting out
of it what am i giving out of it and if
it is a net positive then for me like it
makes it worth it and then having people
around me surrounding myself with people
who are incredibly supportive and who
makes the work fun that that is what
makes it all worthwhile but yeah I don't
ever look in the mirror and think oh my
god like dude you can't do this anymore
like I don't have it if I ever do come
to that if I'm ever if I'm ever at the
you know at the end of the show we do
that we do the hug line and if I'm ever
at that hug line and I'm like damn there
are too many people in this hug line I
gotta get I gotta get to sleep I do not
want to be here like this is miserable
if I ever get to that point then I won't
do it and and that's what I would say
about anyone out there who is you know
cultivating a passion or working their
passion is their work is is it a net
positive and if there's something that
is glaring to say hey I don't want to do
this anymore than that is for me it
would be something it would be a sign
for me of something internal saying hey
dude maybe you shouldn't do this anymore
maybe there's something else you need to
move on to do I think it's a different
kind of stress it's I had problems
before for sure my problems growing out
poor I had problems when I was making
great money in my 20s I stuff problems
today but they're better problems and
and that's really what I strive for is
is continuing to improve upon those I'm
not gonna live a perfect life but it's
more ideal
anytime anything feels out of whack I
just have to go back and look at my
values and say are my actions right now
in line with with my values and and
whenever I feel some sort of discontent
or stress or whatever usually it has to
it has to do with me forsaking one of
those one of those values although I'd
be interested it's got you you mean
you're running an organization with 500
employees and by the way what you do it
saves people's lives so the obverse of
that is what you don't do doesn't save
their lives and that's that's an
incredible responsibility yeah I would
say Thanks this is Scots like oh I never
thought of it that way
I mean basically what I'm saying is if
the people in here don't help it's on
you yeah so you know we've been at it
now 11 years and a lot of people will
come up to us in this is in a very small
social entrepreneurs kind of field and
say you know wow did you guys ever think
you would be so successful like did you
ever think you could raise a quarter of
a billion dollars and you know currently
we're helping 2,800 people get clean
water every single day of the year so
20,000 people every single week get
clean water for the first time in their
lives I'm like man I first of all I
thought we would be so much farther
honestly 7 million people I thought we'd
be at 70 or 100 by now Wow the you know
our ambition so far exceeds our ability
which is frustrating and I feel like now
for 11 years I've been pushing a boulder
up the hill
I read tipping point it didn't help you
know like literally it's just it gets
harder and harder and now the weight of
responsibility you know we employ 1500
locals actually around the world in 24
countries and well the organization has
to raise about a million dollars a week
to continue serving you know a million
people when we want to raise more so the
the pressure builds and builds and
builds and it gets harder and harder
I yesterday I got off my 46th flight of
the year the year before my first son
was born I did 98 flights and you know
we're flying coach right the
organization has never bought a
business-class ticket in the history of
charity:water so it's it gets harder and
harder and harder more more speeches
more meetings more more travel to these
countries and I think that the the life
the one quote I came across of ten years
ago that's really been a driving force
for me it actually comes from an ancient
Jewish text it's a vote rabbi Natan I
think and it's this is amazing quote
that says do not be afraid of work that
has no end I love that right don't be
afraid now then it begs the question
what are you working for
all right so if your work is in the
service of others if it's using your
time and your talent and your money you
know to alleviate suffering to reach out
to serve others it will have no end
right I'm so sick of hearing about
charities putting themselves out of
business like if we when we get everyone
on earth access to clean water together
as this huge global community trying to
do this you know we're not gonna go drop
the mic and go work at Goldman Sachs
right we're gonna turn everything we've
learned over decades our generous
community of millions and millions of
people on another issue on another form
of human suffering maybe it's hunger
maybe it's shelter maybe we believe
everyone should have a roof over their
head you know one should go to bed
hungry but we're not just like that's
the pursuit so it's a never-ending
pursuit of service or selflessness if
you know I think all of us were kind of
trapped in the the never-ending pursuit
of materialism of more stuff more status
better cars better you know whatever
more more people to say nice things
about our better job titles trophies
trophies so I love that don't be afraid
of work that has no end but really ask
yourself what are you working towards
love it Thanks your question thank you
thanks all right it is time for our
lightning round this is where we usually
answer questions from social media but
you're here so we'll answer your
questions let's do two light lightning
round questions and we'll do one bonus
round question or overtime question
we'll get to that in a sec so what we do
is we try to give you a short shareable
lesson hundred and forty character
response something pithy that you can
tweet by the way Jessica runs our social
media she's here taking pictures and
live tweeting right from our account
we're at the minimalists on Facebook and
the instagrams and the Twitter's so
ladies and gentlemen Jessica Williams
whoever she is so you give us a regular
question we'll try to give you a pithy
answer and if we can't have something
pithy we'll ramble on until we get
something pithy for you what's your name
my name is Frank hey Frank originally
from Brooklyn so my question is cover
well currently I'm in a job where I just
get up and go through the motions and
got to pay the bills and render all that
stuff and thanks to my supportive
boyfriend over here I'm trying to pursue
my passions which is creative writing
and currently in October coming up I'm
going to be taking some creative writing
courses so I think what I'm trying to
say is how do you get over that fear of
trying to leave a safe job and go for
what you're truly passionate about I'm
not going to just get up and go but the
idea of you know having a pension and
having benefits and all that stuff to
really pursue something that you feel
amazing about how did you guys really
get over that past that I think my
tweetable answer is something like
security is a misnomer you know I I had
the the secure job where I was living
paycheck to paycheck and I was I was you
know one dismissal away or if the
company was sold I I was two paychecks
away it's about a month away from danger
from emergency right we have a friend
his name is Rob Bell and
he was he was on our podcast recently
and he hears his don't steal his pithy
answer most emergencies aren't but but
we treat everything like it's an
emergency these days and thus I think we
tell ourselves that the path were on is
secure oh here's my pit the answer for
you I knew I'd get to it I knew I knew
we'd get there it is not the security
blanket that brings one security it's
good man if I to get but the only thing
I could think is like men living living
the lifestyle I was living and having to
have the job to maintain that lifestyle
it was it just felt like a really bad
tornado very bad hurricane and the only
I guess my pity answer would be he's
composing the draft to have a job that
brings you security so you can live a
life that you hate is never worth it
[Music]
yeah you're on the hot seat sir oh hey
oh man you can reach me I'm not the
right person to ask about that question
I mean for me it was obviously much more
radical there was no Sookie I mean
nightclub promoters are not good at
saving money so if you are a month away
like I was like two days away
you know I sold everything and made a
little bit of money there but I you know
hearing you who ever talked earlier just
saying that they it was you you you know
being in a job you hate like that just
makes us all cringe you know that's such
a horrible you know doing something that
you don't love because it pays the bills
like you gotta find a way out and I
loved you know having a plan maybe don't
just leave and
you know and then you're like on the
street or yeah but but work you know
take the classes go and you know earn
some income on the side find a way you
know to that path and it sounds like you
know what that is
you want to write you know you want to
find a way to be creative and and turn
that into the thing that you do for a
living
so I would spend as much time trying to
get there coming up with a plan
experimenting with things and you know
making sure a few years from now you
know you're not in a job that's just
paying the bills so you're doing your
thing on the side you had the Pippy
answer in there you're gonna help so so
I've heard of tweeze it out Air France
he said well no verbatim you said you
said if you're working a job you hate
just to pay the bills get out yeah
anyone seen the movie get out I don't
yeah yeah so not not a spoiler but I
feel like you're in the sunken place
right now and some of you will get that
others will eventually thank you so much
for the information okay thank you
thanks brother appreciate it make sure
you come see me afterward and grab a hug
there free and transferable I will do
one more lightning round question howdy
what's your name very happy to be here
give it up for the support of sister
[Applause]
struggling and we both have people in
our lives who are not supportive so the
question is this I want to pursue
minimalism I want to get on the track I
listen to everything every podcast and I
just joined the patreon page even though
I have to pay my bills I can't afford
that
so I'm very happy about that - I'm proud
of it so the question is if I want to
pursue minimalism my husband does not
and I know what you've said before you
have to be accepting of who that person
is to China to force them right but I
full-fledged want to go in I think
Valerie will too
after tonight so I know I could get the
support from her but I live with him
that's you know the issue it's simple
when he's not when he's not home you
just pack up all the stuff yeah hang on
don't say my mind was gonna be simple
just throw his stuff out but I do that I
do it I don't know I'm not supposed to I
do geez guys I'll help you deal with the
consequent do that thank goodness shot
podcast Shawn is here we have a good
editor I have two words for you house
fire they'll never track it back to you
it's totally fine this podcast won't be
sent out to a million people yeah okay
so actually it's it's it's weird we'll
get people come up to us and after our
Vince like really emotionally bleh like
my house just flooded or it just caught
on fire and I feel so relieved now I'm
not telling you to do that in fact I'm
telling you not to just to be clear but
what what I am saying is they didn't
realize that before the thing happened
to them right and so what needs to
happen to your husband isn't you forcing
anything on him
it's it's it's leading by example it's
showing the benefits now the benefits
may be different for him than they are
for you but some of the benefits are
gonna be shared it's gonna be sort of
this Venn diagram of benefits and
there's happiness contentment feeling
lighter having better give finances more
time whatever those shared benefits are
gonna be but then some of the benefits
are gonna be different for him and
you're gonna have to show those not tell
him and so I guess my pithy answer would
be is a forced minimalism ain't
minimalism indeed um you know when it
comes to any relationship I think
especially romantic relationship there
are there are certain levels to kind of
get through and you mentioned one which
was accepting and I think below
acceptance is is probably tolerance
which is kind of a weak virtue it's like
when I'm stuck in traffic in LA
everyone's tolerant they're not like
necessarily happy but they're tolerant
they'll let you over but then you know
after that I think you moved to the
acceptance and then it goes to respect
and then to the point where you
appreciate the person so it's not just
accepting who
who your husband is or him accepting you
it's about getting to that that point of
appreciation what I'll say is that it is
a two-way street
so for as much support and as much
respect as you give your husband it is
something that if he gives that back to
you it's gonna help the relationship
flourish so I think my pithy answer
would be don't spend too much time
investing in people who don't invest in
you and and I'm not I'm not telling you
to get a divorce this is not this is not
what I'm saying but what I'm saying is
is that if you do work on those steps
and you can get to that point where you
can truly show them that you do respect
them and that you do appreciate the
differences and you kind of look at this
minimalist journey as your own journey I
promise you you will move him because
the worst thing anyone could be like
think about someone who is like I was
raised a really hardcore Jehovah's
Witness and which is basically just like
a really strict Christian religion and I
remember I would get into an argument
with not even an argument discussion a
very nice discussion argument is not the
right word with like a seventh-day
adventists
and we would have that both we both have
the same thing in our mind of oh I'm
gonna convert this guy oh yeah I'm gonna
convert this guy and when I would get
into those conversations I never ever
went when they were trying to get me to
their side I never ever budged an inch
towards their side of anything I moved a
foot back I held on to my to those
values that are those beliefs I should
say that I had even even stronger so yes
going into the forest minimalism do not
get rid of your husband's stuff because
that's just gonna make it's just gonna
piss them off even more and make him
step back but the way that you can the
way that you can get someone to move
forward is to respect them love them and
appreciate them like that is what will
help bring your husband over to your
side and you guys may never be on the
same level when it comes to minimalism
but I promise you if you can get to that
appreciation point
you're going to have a very happy
relationship okay thank you you
everything Pippi you even tie this up
with a bow yes you can quietly start
without him that is so good it's so true
you don't have to go to him be like all
right husband today we're gonna start
our minimalist journey yes you can
absolutely start quietly that's that's
the best one out of the three I think
actually Scott just steals the around
there
all right you a quick interruption if
you want to listen to our bonus episode
this week as well as all of our past
bonus episodes head on over to the
minimalists dot-com and click donate at
the top of our website each week we
publish the minimalists private podcast
exclusively for our patreon supporters
this private podcast shows up in your
normal podcast feed like Apple podcasts
overcast Google Play or whatever podcast
app you use and it shows up right next
to our normal weekly podcast you know
the one you're listening to right now
and being a patreon supporter also gets
you first access to the best tickets to
all of our live events as well as access
to our monthly private livestream video
which is called ask the minimalists
anything it's worth noting that none of
this money goes to me or to Ryan instead
we're using your contributions to build
a new podcast in film studio in Los
Angeles so that we can create more
meaningful audio and video creations if
you already support this podcast thank
you I know that $2 often doesn't sound
like a lot of money I mean it's less
than a cup of coffee but it is your
support that keeps this podcast 100%
advertisement free because
advertisements suck and if we can just
get 2% of our audience to support this
show then we'll have enough funds to
produce some amazing new creations your
support is truly appreciated alright
y'all back to the regular show alright
real quick we'll have to wrap this up
they're gonna kick us out of the theater
I really don't want to apologize the
folks who didn't get a chance to ask
questions I do want to thank a few
people before before we get out of here
we are on tour
now we have a tour manager a road
manager a podcast producer podcast
editor book editor all in one human
being he's our operations manager he's
really the guy behind the minimalism
ladies and gentleman hiding in the
shadows in the back podcast Sean Thank
You Sean and I don't know if Jake is
still hanging out around here my guess
is he is but we've been hanging out with
the folks from Nightline they're trying
to get more attention on this and
hopefully what via Nightline will be
able to shed some more light on the
charity:water
stuff as well so Jake if you're here
thank you for helping us get the message
into the eyes and ears of more people
thank you so much
and Scott I want to thank you for being
here I want to just acknowledge you and
and say thank you so much for what you
do man you're making the world a better
place and I'm really grateful for that
and if you leave here with just one
message we hope it's this love people
and use things because the opposite
never works thanks y'all
I rhyme before we backflip into these
comments from our readers and readers
and they've reading our podcast I know
you do a backflip I don't know I could
do a backflip I know I could read a
podcast kiss podcast oh we're not gonna
read it you know that was a great it was
a great live event and we just now
ruined it yeah we're good at that though
I'd apologize but I'm not sorry my back
flipped and hit my head on the diving
board apparently anyway before we
backflip into these these listener
comments and tips my favorite part of
the show we just want to say thanks to
Scott Harrison and we hope that you all
support charity:water if you just have a
few bucks five bucks you can donate to
charity water it's a great cause they're
doing some really great things charity
water.org slash the minimalist there's
another way to contribute if you're
going to be in the Las Vegas area in
January January 14th we're doing a
charity event a hundred percent of the
profits go to the Victims Fund after
this terrible mass shooting that
happened we wanted to find a way to give
back there locally and so we decided to
add one additional less is now tour stop
there in Las Vegas so it's a normal tour
stop but 100 percent of the profits go
to the Victims Fund it's the House of
Blues on January 14th that's a Sunday
it's a long holiday weekend so hopefully
you can make it out that place seats a
bunch of people if we can fill it out up
we can raise a lot of money for all the
victims there you find the ticket
details over at the minimalists com oh
and one more oh actually a couple more
cities we're going to we're going to
Milwaukee and Detroit that ins the less
is now tour this year so I think there's
still some tickets available for both of
those events Detroit and Milwaukee the
minimalists calm and you can also go to
that website because we're going to
Australia and New Zealand next year
those events are selling out quickly and
they're huge theaters so please get your
tickets before you start tweeting us a
month from now saying hey I waited too
long I can't get my tickets I'm sorry
like once the seats are full the seats
are full I can't
can't book a ticket for you to sit on
someone else's lab laughs or kind of
show lap seats net oh my goodness
someone someone write that down yeah
someone write down that terrible idea
John anyway we're gonna be so yeah we're
going to New Zealand Australia we'll be
in Detroit Milwaukee and Vegas come on
out and see us and one last reminder
don't buy the bag that we just made
you've probably heard us the last few
weeks we created something called the
packed one it's the bag that you see in
our documentary that we that was we used
for we still use have used for the
better part of a decade though the one
item I've gotten the most value from in
the last decade is it's either that
phone that I'm holding in my hand right
now
or that bag but truth be told it would
be much harder to travel the way that we
travel if I didn't have a bag that works
really well for me but here's the thing
it may not work well for you and you
probably don't need another bag and
especially if you can't afford to buy a
bag it's not that expensive but if you
can't afford it we certainly encourage
you not to buy it don't go into debt
don't put it on a credit card that you
can't pay off by the end of the month
it's not worth that it's a great bag we
found a lot of value in it that's all we
started an IndieGoGo campaign just for
the bag to see how many people really
need the bag but that word need is the
key word here if you if you don't need
the bag if you just want to consume it
on impulse then step back think about it
for a second and see whether or not it
really is for you and the truth is it's
not for most people and that's totally
okay but if you are excited about it and
you really want the bag and head on over
to the minimalists comm slash bag you
can find the trailer there you can find
out more information and maybe some
reason more reasons well write down some
more reasons why you shouldn't buy this
bag man if there was only like a
two-minute meditation that people could
go to that was last week and listen to
before they purchase any new item that
they bring into the light that would be
so helpful yeah so if you're a patreon
supporter then you have access to our
two-minute anti-consumerism meditation
or you can find that meditation and the
other black friday meditation that we
did for our friend dan harris who was in
our documentary he has a great
meditation app called 10% happier and he
has
a bunch of different meditations he
releases on there we just want to help
him out this is definitely not an ad for
that he doesn't pay us a penny to to
mention his podcast what he has a great
podcast as well but for his app but he's
a good friend and he I mean his app is
the best meditation app that we've ever
used so that's why we decided to help
out all right yeah let's listen to these
comments and tips from our backflipping
listeners my name is Annabelle and I'm
calling from Munich Germany this message
is for Leah from Montreal who asked
about reconciling minimalism and the
desire to have a wedding Leah my friend
I've been you the one thing I always
wanted was a big and beautiful wedding
and once I got it I didn't really want
it anymore I have the coolest husband in
the world now but our wedding wasn't
exactly a walk in a field of ponies we
spent $15,000 which were our entire
savings plus three thousand dollars in
credit card debt just to be smothered
for eight hours by a few hundred
well-intentioned guests who quote
absolutely needed a selfie with the
bride and it's not that we didn't stick
to our list of priorities or that we
overspent on say things or that
something in particular went wrong we
just couldn't possibly cram enough
enjoyment into this day to call it the
best day of our lives and justify the
expense there are industries that sell
you stuff and then there are industries
that sell you an idea of who you're
supposed to be as a person so when you
plan this ritual with your partner think
about the verb to love not the noun
bride I'm sure you are more beautiful in
PJs doing what you're passionate about
then squeeze into a huge white gown
doing what society expects you to do
your family and your fiance probably
think so too if all else fails and you
must have a wedding in the classical
sense of the world I can share this one
piece of advice / your guest list in
half be ruthless you will have much more
one-on-one time with the people you
truly love as for my hubby and me we
enjoyed the Wednesday afternoon field
trip to City Hall
dressed in jeans with our two best
friends much more than
party the weekend after best of luck
darling hi this is Roxana from Austin
Texas I wanted to follow up with a high
school student that had called earlier
in one of the podcasts about not going
into debt for college and actually
earning 10,000 a year during high school
well I wanted to give her an advice I
graduated without any debt in college
and she doesn't actually have to earn
all of the money while she's in college
what you can do is earn part of the
money but then along the way there's the
summers where you're off and you have
you get internships and I know she was
going to go into dental hygiene but she
doesn't have to take an internship or a
job in one of those at the end she can
go into an internship or a career that
would pair well and I just want to
encourage her to keep doing what she's
doing but there is time while you're in
college to actually also earn that money
you don't have to have all the money
before you get there and that doesn't
mean that you have to take out the money
in loans it just means that you can also
work and earn while you're in college so
good luck I hope everything goes well
sir hi my name is Michelle and I'm
flying to answer a question asked on
episode 97 high five Hutt from Jean from
Sacramento she mentioned moving into a
tiny house and the accouterments that
come along with the life-sustaining
hobby of cooking yes when you cook how
long does it take you and what do you
make and our family my husband and I
arrange for cooking for 20 minutes two
hours and even days for some of the
recipes I really wanted to call because
my husband and I dream of having a tiny
house and someday there's half of it
being a kitchen so I had several
recommendations for him
first was a kitchen supplies Alton
Brown's book here for your kitchen was
really helpful for me he's very critical
of what he refers to as unit casters or
tools that only do one job second is a
subscription to America's Test Kitchen
online if you're stopping good stuff
they have really helpful reviews the
next tested everything very thoroughly
then per minimal of cooking the brothers
green eats on YouTube has brief
well-made videos
and in the early episodes they're
cooking in a small apartment kitchen so
that may be helpful to you
lastly I would advise considering how
everything will work together for
example my husband has been pining after
an induction cooktop if we were getting
one for a tiny house I would keep her
pressure cooker and eliminate our rice
cooker maybe invest in a pan that was
nest in the pressure cooker for storage
if we were instead investing in an inch
the pot or something similar then I'd
have a really different plan I maybe
want to single gaspin burner in addition
so I hope for you everything is going
well and you're able to make decisions
that help you downsize while keeping
your choices on things that you value
[Music]
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your green oh I bet that you'll
be fine without
[Music]
every little thing that you gotta have
every little thing that you got you
gotta reach for and you got a grand oh I
bet that you'll be fine without your
team
[Music]
you